heck it's somewhere if this was a boil
on it
seriously I miss to eat that you have to
tell me if I can't eat it it's almost
like the inside of a Nutter Butter but
better than another butter it's so nutty
I taste like it needs to be cooked it's
like raw cookie dough this is fancy
like something you'd see at a really
fancy tea party of eternal last century
I wish more American desert for sparkly
I would like to make jewelry out of it
though India I'm into your desserts it's
comfort do not want you getting
introduced is this a banana why is it so
Wiggly
the size of the little intimidating well
that's really good I would totally eat
this tastes like a gourmet cupcake this
is so good Wow where we've been I like
this log Jen I eat the whole thing
oh good this is the ginn bond
Jesus hmm let's touch it cold colder
than I thought
this is it'll be very confusing it
smells good what secrets do you hold oh
my god oh my robe
you can literally ring this out but
that's like a magic trick it's good I
like it looks like a golden potato it's
almost overwhelming it's like a
saturated syrup sack good amount of
grease it seems like the majority of
Indiana desserts are balls but it tastes
like a really really good doughnut it's
almost too good well like our hands get
so messy that's what makes me feel a
little guilty I know No
oh my god it's beautiful
oh whoa so sticky whoa just got real
this is something like Americans would
get at a carnival sure I would eat this
at the fair and then you would
immediately throw up on the first ride
that you went on there's a lot to handle
yeah boopity goop this is a bit light
[ __ ] bless whoever made this oh my gosh
how does this exist